guten Morgen Anna
morgen Anna bist du bereit ja perfekt
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein richtig geniales
Gemüselasagne Rezept für euch
[Musik]
dieses Rezept habe ich neulich auf dem
Grill draußen zubereitet richtig lecker
richtig genial eine tolle Gemüsereste
Verwertung ihr habt doch gar nicht so
viele Nudeln mit dabei also auch ein
bisschen Low Carb ihr könnt auch die
Nudelblätter komplett weglassen wenn ihr
wollt ohne reine Gemüse Lasagne machen
super lecker und wie gesagt ihr dürft
entscheiden ob es draußen auf dem Grill
zubereitet oder hier ich habe sogar die
Tomatensoße draußen gegrillt und
praktisch in der Ofenform einfach nur
gekocht habe das Gemüse draußen
angebraten und dann alles in die
Ofenform geschichtet und auf dem Grill
gestellt das ist mega denn ich muss
sagen nach Feierabend und am Wochenende
bin ich einfach am liebsten draußen und
Koch draußen ich zeige euch mal kurz die
Zutaten gebe ich bereits mein Gemüse ich
nehme zwei Zucchinis zwei Auberginen und
drei rote spitzfabrik etwas Olivenöl für
die Soße eine Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehe
50 Gramm Tomatenmark 400 Gramm Tomaten
aus der Dose oder auch gerne frische
Tomaten die habe ich noch Sardellen und
Kapern etwas Salz und Pfeffer eine Prise
Zucker und etwas Oregano
Oregano oder Oregano das ist die Frage
früher habe ich immer gesagt Oregano
dann hat mich jemand korrigiert seitdem
sage ich auch gerne jetzt korrigieren
mich Menschen wieder und sagen nein das
heißt Oregano wie heißt denn jetzt nun
so ich weiß es noch also beim Gemüse
entscheidet ihr selbst was ihr nehmen
wollt das ist jetzt so ein bisschen
mediterran würde ich mal sagen so ein
bisschen italienisch türkisch angehaucht
aber wenn er sagt ihr wollten anderes
Gemüse dann nur so
bei den Auberginen achte ich drauf die
wird jetzt erst einmal fein gewürfelt
bzw grob gewürfelt also jetzt nicht
Zufall und dann gesalzen das sieht dann
einfach so ein bisschen die Bitterstoffe
auch raus und die Zucchini die Aubergine
und die Aubergine nimmt da nicht so viel
Fett auf also das ist echt ganz gut
[Musik]
einfach hier reingeben
bisschen Salz drüber da jetzt auch keine
Sorge das Salz wird später wieder
rausgewaschen jetzt kann ich das Gemüse
schneiden aber das mache ich gleich ich
werde jetzt erstmal die Tomatensoße
Kochen dafür einfach die Zwiebel und
Knoblauch sehr fein hacken und mit
Olivenöl anbraten
wenn die Zwiebel und die Knoblauchzehe
angebraten sind gebt ihr jetzt das
Tomatenmark dazu mit den Tomaten aus der
Dose ablöschen und dann kommen die
Kapern und die Sardellen dazu ich weiß
viele mögen keine Kapern und noch keine
Sardellen aber es gibt dieser
Tomatensoße einen richtig einzigartigen
Geschmack deswegen probiert es aus
dieser Dellen die die schmelzen so ein
bisschen in der Soße also die spürt ja
auch später nicht mehr es gibt einfach
einen tollen Geschmack ab und dann wird
es nämlich schon eingekauft
gar nicht rein
was auch immer
Salz und Pfeffer und nicht zu sehr
Salzen denn die Kapern und die Sardellen
sind schon salzig und wenn ich das sagt
als die
überdosiererin was aber nie eigentlich
zu salzig ist gell oder ist nicht salzig
komm
und Prise Zucker
dann Deckel drauf und die Soße etwa 5
bis 10 Minuten einkochen lassen und in
der Zeit schneide ich dann einfach die
Paprika und die Zucchinis in kleine
Würfel
[Musik]
die Aubergine habe ich jetzt gewaschen
und ausgedrückt und jetzt nehmt ihr
Olivenöl packt es in eure Pfanne ich
muss sagen draußen auf dem Grill habe
ich dann wirklich alles hinterher mal
Erfahrung gemacht noch dann immer wieder
raus und praktisch erst das Gemüse
angebraten dann auf Nutella dann
Tomatensoße gegart dann die Tomatensoße
gefüllt und dann eben alles in einer
Form aber so geht es jetzt ein bisschen
schneller alles parallel zubereiten und
jetzt ist Gemüse einfach anbraten das
heißt die Auberginen Paprika und
Zucchini für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten
und dann wird gleich die Lasagne
geschichtet denn
Tomatensoße ist auch schon soweit
ein bisschen salzen und pfeffern und
dann geht es direkt los
ich habe jetzt hier Schmand und etwas
Kräuterfrischkäse das ganze verrührt ihr
einfach miteinander ihr könnt natürlich
auch eine Bechamelsoße kochen aber ich
finde hier ist es einfach ganz gut mit
den zwei Zutaten und dann nehmt ihr euch
eure Auflaufform eure Ofenform ich nehme
jetzt hier einfach die kleine Ecke
myform und ich werde jetzt einfach eine
kleine Portion für uns zubereiten und
eine Portion meine Eltern deswegen nehme
ich einfach zwei Förmchen ihr könnt es
auch so machen dass ihr sowas gut
vorbereitet eine Portion für heute und
die nächsten für morgen in den
Kühlschrank packt oder eine große offene
Form nehmen ganz wie ihr möchtet ich
starte jetzt hier unten erst einmal mit
etwas Tomatensoße
da kommt Gemüse drauf
dann etwas Creme
und Lasagneblätter
und dann wieder von vorne und das
schichtet jetzt so weit wie Ihr möchtet
[Musik]
und ganz oben drauf kommen bei mir
Nudelplatten dann die Käsecreme und am
Ende Mozzarella und dann kommt es schon
in den Ofen oder eben auf den Grill und
achtet bei Lasagne einfach nur drauf
dass es Verhältnis zwischen Feuchtigkeit
und Lasagneblättern stimmt ansonsten
wird sie zu trocken und die Nudelblätter
bleiben hart aber hier im Gemüse habe
ich hier wirklich ganz viel Flüssigkeit
noch drin und viel Feuchtigkeit und so
wird's einfach perfekt
und ab mit dir inneren
[Musik]
das sieht lecker aus
die Form habe ich jetzt nicht so voll
gemacht
damit ich noch eine zweite Form füllen
kann aber das Rezept ist genauso
angelegt dass es für eine Form reicht
wenn es eine schöne hohe Lasagne wird
okay Tolga möchtest du mit mir probieren
möchtest du diese Lasagne mitbringen
ich bin ja eigentlich kein Lasagne Fan
dann hau rein
mit Essiggurken knackige kalte
Essiggurke dazu
in der Lasagne
so und
dann muss
voll cool
Lasagne und wir essen wir die immer mit
Püppchen
und
war ja auch nur die Käseschicht gleich
geht's in der Portion Gemüse bei dir
dazu also falls ihr das Rezept
nachmachen wollt
dann schaut in meiner App vorbei ich
finde es mega lecker Gemüse könnt ihr
abwandeln wie ihr wollt das Rezept ist
schmeckt
perfekt und es ist auch Murat approve
den Murat der eigentlich immer was mit
Fleisch will auch der hat die Lasagne
richtig abgefeiert probiert es aus wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal bis
dahin tschüss
was kommt bei euch denn dazu oder kommt
einfach nichts dazu
[Musik]